One time I was at this karaoke with a
bunch of like some Japanese, some
non-Japanese and I sang my wonder and I
was just looking like I hated it. And
this old Japanese man, his name was
Hiroshi said, "Come sit next to me." And
he said to me, "What you need to
understand about karaoke is it doesn't
matter whether you sing well or sing
badly. What matters is your guests have
a good time." And I didn't really
realize that. I'd been going in with
this like quite
stupid, quite selfish, quite quite
English, quite western mentality, which
is I'm supposed to sing well and I'm
getting self-conscious. And then they
were like, "No, what you want to do is
you want to make everyone else have a
good time." And then I kind of changed
the way that I approached karaoke and I
would try to make a bit of a joke of it
and try to make everybody else enjoy it.
And what what I found was
when I started focusing on making the
other people around me enjoy it more, I
also enjoyed it much more. And I kind of
felt that like this I I being raised in
this like get rich or die trying
culture. I'd kind of allowed myself to
believe that in life you have a choice
between do you take care of yourself or
do you worry about worry about other
people and you have to take care of
yourselves cuz no one is going to take
care of you. And then from my time in
Japan I realized that I think really
personally I think that makes us smaller
as humans to to think that you you can
only be all for me or or nothing for me.
I think that we have the capacity as
humans to both be selfish and care for
ourselves and I think that you have to
do that. you have if you don't care
about look after you who's going to look
after you and also care for others you
know I think that we've really made made
people smaller in by convincing them
that they that they have to be selfish I
think and that means that they can't
give as well I think like 100% you can
do both you should do Oh.